the real underlying deeper cellular
cause of autism involves
oxidative stress to neurons leading to
neuronal toxicity and inflammation
basically there's inflammation in the
brain and there's a lot of free radical
damage but there's not enough
antioxidant protection to counter that
now your body makes antioxidants and
they can come from the diet but I did a
huge Deep dive into this topic and I
found some really interesting
information on some common deficiencies
okay with many people who have autism
number one they tend to have low amounts
of antioxidants I already mentioned that
especially glutathione that's the master
antioxidant in the body that does a
tremendous amount of work in protecting
you and getting rid of toxicity and free
radical damage there's also low vitamin
A there's low vitamin E low vitamin D
there's low zinc selenium low magnesium
and low omega-3 there's also
mitochondrial dysfunction which is not
surprising because anytime you have
oxidant stress you're going to have
problems in the mitochondria deep within
the neuron and there's also something
called High homocysteine which you may
connect with heart problems but in this
case it can create degenerative symptoms
in the brain and the solution for that
is B12 and folate in a certain form
which I'll cover in a bit and there's
also amino acid abnormalities probably
because of all the oxidation going on
these amino acids are really important
because they actually the raw material
for all the enzymes in the biochemical
Pathways So based on that data the best
diet that I would recommend would be a
version of the carnivore diet because
that will eliminate so many potential
allergic type reactions that the
person's having including the gluten
intolerance problem or gluten allergy or
a casein allergy or whatever because a
lot of people who have autism have food
allergies and that creates more
oxidative stress so anything we can do
to take the load off this oxidative
stress by eliminating any potential
allergic type things is going to be
really good and within that carnivore
diet I would include eggs okay because
you're going to get a lot of vitamin A
in the egg yolk as well as other
minerals and vitamins I would also
include seafood and even shellfish even
though there might be a little bit more
higher Mercury you're also at the same
time going to get higher levels of
selenium and zinc in other trace
minerals which are very protective
against these heavy metals I would also
include Oregon Meats like liver beef
liver if you don't like liver either get
a good recipe or camouflage it in
hamburger or take grass-fed liver pills
because not only does liver have pretty
much everything that I mentioned
including B12 and folate and zinc and
selenium but it's also a really good
source of these amino acids that I
mentioned and it has something else Co
Q10 that is very very powerful for the
mitochondria and that can be extremely
helpful what I'm trying to do in this
protocol is instead of loading up with a
lot of different vitamins I'm trying to
include the foods that contain those
vitamins so you wouldn't have to take
every single nutrient Now The Tweak to
this carnivore diet which will make it
not quite carnivore it's going to make
it more more of a ketogenic plan because
we're going to add a little bit of carbs
but not too much you would add micro
greens or Sprouts now if you could find
microgreens grown in soil that would be
the ultimate why because these baby
plants okay like roughly about seven to
ten days are some of the most vital
nutrient antioxidant Rich things that
you can possibly eat and some of them
are loaded with sulforaphane which is an
effective known remedy for autism
microgreens and Sprouts are basically
antioxidants on steroids now to build up
glutathione there's two things you have
a remedy called NAC which helps
indirectly build up glutathione and
selenium now you could take selenium as
a supplement or if you're doing
shellfish or seafood you're going to get
a good amount of selenium now another
really important remedy would be cod
liver oil why because it's the perfect
EPA DHA
Omega-3s as well as vitamin A and
vitamin D and the person who has autism
might need more vitamin D in which case
the best thing to do is to expose
themselves to a lot of sun okay without
getting burnt
they can't do that like in the winter
then take a good vitamin D3 supplement
at least 10 000 IUS per day probably
more like maybe even 20 000 IUS that's
going to act as a very potent
anti-inflammatory now if you're not
doing the beef liver because you don't
like liver or you're not going to do the
pills then I recommend that you get
um the type of B12 and folate that can
help lower homocysteine and greatly help
this condition the form of B12 that you
need to take is called
methylcobolamine not the cyanocobolamine
that many people take that they don't
realize it's just a synthetic version
it's not the right one and then the type
of folate they need is something called
methylfolate not folic acid now as far
as coenzyme Q10 you could get that in
orgamates but it is a very effective
measure to improve your mitochondria so
you may want to add that to the list
with this extra thing called methylene
blue you can order on Amazon or get it
from the health food store but methylene
blue is very very interesting I've done
videos about it and depending on the age
of the person let's say they're a child
I would recommend maybe 10 drops it's a
very small amount if they're older maybe
take 20 drops and both 10 to 20 drops is
a very small dosage and you would put
that in a glass of water you might want
to add some electrolytes to it and sip
it with a straw because methylene blue
can greatly help reduce the oxidative
stress in the mitochondria taking the
pressure off the neurons
improving the symptoms of autism so
there you have it that's the plan that I
would recommend and if you have not seen
my video on sulforaphane and autism you
should check that out I put it up right
here